la séance est ouverte le compte-rendu
intégral de la séance du jeudi 16
février a été publié sur le site
internet du Sénat nous n'avons pas reçu
d'observation
il y en a t-il en séance
je n'en vois pas
le procès-verbal est donc adopté
madame
la première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues le port du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
notre séance est retransmise en
direction Public Sénat et notre site
internet chacun sera attentif au respect
des uns et des autres et de celui du
temps de parole je vais donner la parole
tout de suite à notre collègue
Tani Mohamed Souali pour le groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrates
progressiste et indépendant vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
garde des sceaux le gouvernement a pris
la mesure des enjeux liés à la justice
dans notre pays puisqu'en 5 ans le
budget qui lui est consacré à augmenter
de plus de 40%. vous avez fait de la
mise en œuvre d'une politique de justice
de proximité l'une de vos priorités et
le groupe RDPI s'en réjouit l'objectif
poursuivi est d'apporter une réponse
judiciaire concrète et rapide aux petits
actes de délinquance qui pèse lourdement
sur le sentiment de sécurité et le bien
vivre ensemble et dont le traitement
jusqu'à présent entamer la confiance des
citoyens envers l'institution judiciaire
ce besoin de réassurance tout comme le
redressement de notre justice passe par
des mesures supplémentaires financiers
tout d'abord et c'est avec satisfaction
que nous observons de manière inédite et
pour la troisième année consécutive que
le budget augmente de plus 8%. l'humain
également avec le lancement d'un vaste
plan d'embauche de permettra et de
fonctionnaires le renfort qui a été
apporté au magistrat depuis 2020 de 2000
contractuelles notamment a permis une
réduction significative des affaires en
attente de jugement ce dont nous nous
félicitons lors d'un déplacement au
tribunal judiciaire de Reims vous avez
annoncé la CDI
contractuels cette mesure participe
participera à la lutte contre la
précarité et l'emploi dans la fonction
publique de l'emploi dans la fonction
publique vous avez également signifié
votre intention de poursuivre la
consolidation de l'équipe pour les
magistrats et avec le recrutement de 300
juristes assistants supplémentaire et la
création de la fonction d'attaché de
justice monsieur le garde des sceaux
pourriez-vous nous préciser quels seront
les contours de cette nouvelle fonction
d'attacher de justice ainsi que le
calendrier du déploiement du plan
d'action pour la justice que vous avez
présenté à l'issue des États généraux
on vous répond de la parole comme
Monsieur Eric Dupond-Moretti garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice monsieur
le garde des sceaux vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président et mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Mohamed swahili grâce au budget
que le Sénat a voté à chaque fois depuis
trois ans les 2000 contractuels dont les
900 juristes assistants que nous avons
recruté ont apporté depuis 2017 une aide
particulièrement précieuse au magistrat
et au greffier de notre pays d'ailleurs
nous avons obtenu un déstockage des
dossiers en attente en matière civile de
l'ordre de 30%
grâce à madame la Première ministre j'ai
annoncé dès lundi le recrutement de 300
juristes assistants supplémentaires
cette année cependant leur statut actuel
vous le savez est insatisfaisant trop
précaire il ne prévoit aucune formation
pas davantage que la définition des
tâches qui sont les leurs c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai décidé de
créer une fonction d'attacher de justice
ouverte tant aux fonctionnaires qu'au
contractuel pour que partout dans nos
territoires les attacher de justice
soient présents l'émission seront
définies les attachés de justice
prêteront serment ils recevront une
formation donnée par le nm il formeront
par ailleurs un vivier indispensable au
recrutement massif de 1500 magistrats à
venir
une passerelle spécifique leur
permettant l'accès à le nm sera envisagé
et enfin tous les contractuels justice
de proximité de catégorie A B et C
seront CDI dans leur poste afin de
concrétiser ces annonces je présenterai
la nouvelle loi de programmation de
justice et son volet organique au Sénat
à la fin du mois de mai elle sera une
nouvelle étape du travail conjoint et
constant que nous avons conduit depuis
plusieurs années ensemble chancellerie
et Sénat je vais en particulier monsieur
le sénateur vous remercier je veux
également rendre hommage à toute la
commission des lois et à son président
François Noël buffet nous ferons tout
cela
pour renforcer les moyens dans notre
justice à tellement besoin
et donner la parole à notre collègue
David à Soline pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre comme vous le savez il
y a une énorme attente du débat qui va
commencer ici demain et ce d'autant plus
que celui à l'Assemblée nationale qui
n'a même pas été jusqu'au principal
articles à offert un spectacle parfois
des Holland pourtant quand il a eu lieu
il a été éclairant sur les femmes qui
contrairement à vos affirmations sont
les principales victimes de votre texte
mais aussi quand vous nous parliez des
prétendus 1,8 millions de concernés par
une retraite minimum à 1200 euros devenu
40000 et finalement de 10 à 20 000 au
Sénat nous la gauche nous allons
poursuivre ce travail de vérité nous
serons en écho avec une très grande
majorité de nos concitoyens et avec des
syndicats Unis qui appellent à ce que
notre pays s'arrête que 7 mars pour dire
non à cette régression sociale nous
débattrons cet que 7 qui est un impôt
sur la vie des plus modestes et chacune
et chacun ici devra prendre ses
responsabilités par son vote pour ou
contre deux ans de plus pour celles et
ceux qui ont déjà travaillé dur toute
leur vie mais nous sommes ici attachés
au débat de fond et le fond comme la
démocratie demande du temps celui de
l'argumentation et de l'écoute celui de
l'amendement et de l'explication de vote
libre pour chacun qui sont des droits
sacrés des parlementaires alors je vous
le demande allez-vous encore empêcher ce
débat en le brutalisant en le menaçant
d'interruption alors qu'il s'agit d'une
loi qui touche à la vie de millions de
nos concitoyens faute d'avoir recherché
un accord acceptable avec les syndicats
est-ce que cette limitation fait partie
de l'accord des droites que vous auquel
vous avez consacré tant d'énergie
que vous avez négocié avec LR au Sénat
pour faire passer cette réforme injuste
et inutile
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre du Travail du fait d'emploi de
l'insertion Monsieur Olivier dusse vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur à
souligne permettez-moi de vous répondre
en trois points d'abord sur les
conditions et la durée du débat le
gouvernement bien évidemment espère que
le débat qui s'ouvre demain au Sénat
permettra d'examiner de débattre de
discuter de chacune des dispositions du
projet de loi et ainsi d'avoir un débat
éclairé sur la totalité des articles la
totalité des dispositions et la totalité
du projet vous dites à raison d'une
certaine manière que le débat et
l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas pu aller
au bout mais ce n'est pas au
gouvernement qu'il faut faire le
reproche c'est à vos alliés ce sont à
vos alliés de la France insoumise qui
avec 18 000 amendements parfois quelques
outrances nous n'oublions pas permis
d'aller au bout vous dites monsieur le
sénateur qu'il veut que se débat sera
pour vous l'occasion de pointer des
vérités permettez-moi d'en rappeler une
et de confirmer un chiffre que vous avez
donné avec cette réforme de retraite
nous prévoyons une pension minimale pour
les assurer qui ont cotisé toute leur
carrière au niveau du SMIC et je vous
confirme deux chiffres un que vous avez
cité grâce à cette pension parmi les 17
millions de retraités que compte
aujourd'hui notre pays un million 800
000 bénéficieront d'une revalorisation
et la moitié d'entre eux auront une
valorisation entre 70 et 100 euros
peut-être que vous ne trouvez que c'est
pas assez mais ça signifie si vous ne
trouvez pas assez ça pas assez si vous
êtes assez déconnecté du niveau des
petites pensions et de l'importance de
la revalorisation pour celle-ci et puis
cette réforme elle va permettre à un
nouveau retraité sur 4 200 000 par an
d'avoir là aussi une pension meilleure
avec la perspective puisque c'est notre
objectif de garantir 85 % du SMIC pour
une carrière complète payée au niveau du
SMIC enfin monsieur le sénateur vous
dites chacun devra prendre ses
responsabilités c'est une réalité nous
travaillons avec tous les groupes qui le
souhaitent et si nous pouvons avancer
sur les droits familiaux avec la
majorité sénatoriale j'en serai le
premier heureux mais prendre ses
responsabilités c'est aussi assumer les
positions de votre famille politique
j'ai entendu votre chef de partie
monsieur fort défendre la retraite à 60
ans avec 43 annuité és c'est une machine
à décote c'est une machine à pauvreté et
c'est une machine à petite pension
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Maryse
carrée pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et sociale européen
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à Madame la Ministre chargée
des collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité la France a subi une sécheresse
météorologique préoccupante avertissait
mardi dernier Météo France en confirmant
que le pays venait de vivre 31 jours
consécutifs sans pluie samedi matin le
président de la République appelé les
agriculteurs à la sobriété sur l'eau en
plein cœur du Salon de l'Agriculture à
Paris dans le bassin à nougaronne et qui
couvre une grande partie du Sud-Ouest le
département des Hautes-Pyrénées est un
véritable château d'eau assurant
l'irrigation des terres jusque dans les
Landes en traversant le Gers mais
jusqu'à quand car on constate année
après année la baisse des nappes
phréatiques on va même jusqu'à manquer
d'eau dans quelques villages de montagne
riches pourtant de leur réseau
hydrographique et c'est plus
qu'inquiétant madame la ministre je sais
que vous prenez la mesure de l'ampleur
de ce phénomène mais aujourd'hui nos
agriculteurs et nous-mêmes nous avons
besoin de réponse car on ne peut pas
uniquement imposer des mesures de
restriction c'est un véritable politique
et ambition aussi quelle stratégie
comptez-vous mettre en oeuvre pour
accompagner notre agriculture dans cette
adaptation indispensable face à la
sécheresse quelle solution au-delà des
économies d'eau nécessaire leur
apporterez-vous et que comptez-vous
faire pour soutenir et faciliter la
création de nouvelles réserves
essentielles à la survie sur nos
systèmes hydrographiques pour nos
besoins quotidiens à nos potables pour
le maintien de la qualité des milieux et
en termes de salubrité publique d'une
part et pour la préservation de notre
agriculture garante de notre
souveraineté alimentaire d'autre part je
vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre déléguée en charge les
collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Carrère je tiens tout d'abord
à excuser Christophe Béchu qui est
actuellement au Gabon dans le cadre du
One forest meat au sommet pour favoriser
la préservation des forêts tropicales la
France métropolitaine connaît
aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit une
sécheresse météorologique préoccupante
cinq départements font déjà l'objet de
restriction les Pyrénées Orientales le
Var l'Isère l'un et les Bouches-du-Rhône
dans les jours qui viennent d'autres
départements feront l'objet d'arrêter de
restriction pris par les préfets le
niveau de précipitation dans les deux
mois qui viennent sera crucial pour
déterminer la situation dans laquelle
nous serons cet été
nous sommes tous concernés et tous les
secteurs d'activités sont concernés
concernant l'agriculture il faut le
rappeler sans eau
il n'y a pas d'agriculture et sans
agriculture on ne se nourrit pas
il faut donc réussir à trouver des
compromis et discuter ensemble pour
trouver des solutions avec Christophe
Béchu nous sommes pleinement mobilisés
les préfets qui coordonnent les sept
grands bassins du pays ont été réunis le
27 février pour planifier les solutions
liées aux problèmes de raréfaction d'eau
auxquelles nos territoires seront
confrontés la prochaine réunion aura
lieu le 6 mars à la demande de la
première ministre une cellule
interministérielle de crise ouvrira au
mois de mars enfin le plan sur l'eau sur
lequel nous travaillons depuis six mois
sera présenté dans les prochaines
semaines suite au chantier sur la
planification écologique sur l'eau il se
penchera sur les questions de sobriété
et de répartition des usages notamment
en matière d'agriculture merci
maintenant
ministre malheureusement ne pourra pas
uniquement passer sur la sobriété et les
efforts d'économie les déficits sont
déjà trop importants sur les bassins
hydrographiques nous avons réellement
besoin de stratégie et qu'en est-il
aujourd'hui par exemple du des
propositions du varen de l'eau qu'il y a
eu il y a quelques années nous voulons
simplification de l'accompagnement pour
de nouvelles réserves merci
la parole est à notre collègue Joël
l'abbé pour le groupe écologie
solidarité territoire
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adressait aux mini de la culture alors
Monsieur le Ministre l'agriculture
biologique traverse actuellement une
très mauvaise passe une chute inédite de
4% de la vente faisant ensuite à des
années de croissance à deux chiffres
madame la Première ministre vous avez
évoqué une aide de soutien à la filière
via un fond d'urgence doté de 10
millions d'euros les acteurs concernés
ont rapidement fait le calcul
170 166 euros en moyenne par ferme juste
le prix d'une paire de bottes pour aller
au champ
de la profession agricole et aujourd'hui
l'ensemble des syndicats agricoles
on va répondre la parole est Monsieur
Olivier Véran
porte-parole du gouvernement j'avais la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Madame et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur jouet Labbé d'abord
je vais le faire une fois parce que je
vais être amené à répondre à six
reprises sur des questions agricoles que
personne n'en prenne ombrage marcéno
ministre en charge de l'agriculture et
chacun peut le comprendre actuellement
au Salon International de l'Agriculture
il m'a donc délégué la lourde tâche de
le représenter ce que je vais tâcher de
faire de mon mieux nous avons conscience
monsieur le sénateur de que la filière
du bio traverse actuellement une crise
vous l'avez dit et c'est notamment une
crise de la demande et c'est sur ce
levier en particulier que nous voulons
et devons agir alors nous avons mis en
place de nombreuses mesures pour
soutenir déjà la production bio et
encourager la consommation
écorigine le crédit d'impôt la
participation de l'État au financement
du nouvel campagne bioflexe a autant de
sel 150 000 euros vous l'avez dit comme
nous l'avions fait en 2022 il y aura
également une campagne assurée via le
plan France 2030 à hauteur de 3 millions
d'euros monsieur le nous avons également
abondé le fond à venir bio de 15
millions au lieu des 8 initialement
prévus dont 2 pour structurer la filière
port bio qui connaît des difficultés
particulières lors des Assises de la bio
le 6 décembre dernier le ministre de
l'Agriculture a demandé à l'Agence Bio
d'engager un travail de structuration de
la filière la consommation en
restauration collective sera elle
stimulée grâce à la campagne de
communication que l'agence va lancer dès
2023 avec le financement du programme de
promotion européen qu'elle a obtenu en
2022 nous avons ouvert la possibilité
aux régions qui le souhaitent de
réexploiter des crédits feders non
utilisés le futur programme ambition bio
sera aussi l'occasion de construire une
véritable filière renouvelée dans sa
stratégie pour l'accompagnement et la
structuration et puis pour apporter des
réponses conjoncturelles face à la
situation actuelle du marché la première
ministre a annoncé l'ouverture d'un fond
d'urgence doté de 10 millions d'euros
qui va soutenir des exploitants des
exploitations bio qui sont en difficulté
immédiate nous avons entendu la demande
de la filière sur un risque que des
exploitations bioc s'écroule l'État les
soutiendra avec une aide de trésorerie
qui sera versée dans les semaines qui
viennent nous encouragerons activement
tous les acteurs notamment la grande
distribution les collectivités locales à
faire la promotion du bio sous la
bannière bioflexe des ce printemps et
une réponse structurelle et pour autant
nécessaire il y aura donc des réponses
qui seront apportées très prochainement
je compléterai ma réponse tout à l'heure
il y a une autre question sur le bio
monsieur l'abbé oui monsieur le ministre
vous donner quelques réponses mais sur
le Global c'est absolument
insatisfaisant je voudrais ici insister
sur l'avenir durable que représente
l'agriculture biologique au regard des
enjeux actuels la préservation de la
qualité de l'eau en qualité mais aussi
en quantité la qualité du sol la qualité
de l'air la préservation de
l'environnement de la biodiversité des
pollinisateurs la préservation aussi de
la santé humaine alors toutes ces
raisons font qu'on se doit de donner de
véritables moyens à l'agriculture
biologique pour qu'elle se développe
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Pierre
mais devient pour le groupe Les
Indépendants Républiques et territoire
monsieur monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre en matière de produits
phyto-fensitosanitaires nous
respecterons désormais le cadre européen
et rien que le cadre européen quels sont
les propos de la première ministre ce
lundi au salon de l'agriculture
largement salué par la profession
l'équation plus de chaleur moins d'eau
plus d'aller acclimatiques moins de
Phyto tout en gardant le niveau de
production suffisant est extrêmement
compliqué à résoudre si rien n'est
impossible nous allons devoir dessiner
une agriculture de demain basée sur
l'innovation la technologie la recherche
et les formations la liste des besoins
est longue mais en priorité je vois
l'optimisation de la ressources en eau
bien sûr l'utilisation de plantes
nouvelle génération l'accélération des
délais d'obtention de l'autorisation de
mise sur le marché de nouvelles mètres
cubes prometteuses la profession se
réjouit des annonces d'un nouveau plan
equophyto 2030 qui doit aider à
uniformiser les techniques agricoles au
niveau européen et nous permettre d'être
cohérents sur les marchés mondiaux
comment pensez-vous que l'État peut
accompagner concrètement la profession
dans ce virage historique pour notre
agriculture
pour vous répondre la parole est pas de
parole du gouvernement Monsieur Olivier
Véran
oui monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Pierre metdevielle merci pour
votre question vous le savez nous sommes
confrontés à une réduction importante du
nombre de substances actives au niveau
européen et c'est un mouvement on peut
se le dire qui n'est pas terminé loin
sans faux c'est un sujet de souveraineté
alimentaire et de transition écologique
et c'est à travers la logique de
planification que nous entendons
concilier ces deux impératifs c'est dans
cet esprit que la première ministre a
annoncé au salon de l'agriculture
l'élaboration d'un plan d'action
stratégique pour renforcer le pilotage
et l'adaptation des techniques de
protection des cultures dans ce plan
ecofito 2030 nous devons assumer
collectivement que le développement des
alternatives est essentiel y compris les
alternatives non chimiques la voie à
suivre elle passait nécessairement par
plus d'agronomie la mobilisation non pas
d'un levier mais de plusieurs leviers et
le renouvellement des pratiques
agricoles et des systèmes de production
cela passe aussi par des moyens
importants pour accompagner les
agriculteurs et massifier les solutions
c'est dans cet esprit que le ministre
travaille avec ambition que nous
puissions collectivement nous inscrire
dans une nouvelle approche d'abord avoir
une stratégie ne plus être sur une
gestion au coût par coup ne plus être en
réaction mais bien en anticipation c'est
ça qu'on appelle la planification ça
passe notamment par une grande plus
grande visibilité sur l'évolution des
solutions en termes de protection des
cultures on veut aussi avancer avec les
professionnels avec les filières avec
les instituts techniques et de recherche
fait en sorte que ce qui peut apparaître
comme une impasse deviennent au fond une
opportunité et donc il faut travailler
étroitement ensemble mobiliser nos
capacités de recherche et de
développement l'état fera sa part bien
sûr mais il faut aussi mobiliser les
centres techniques des filières et les
Chambres d'agriculture troisièmement on
veut avoir une approche globale et donc
ne pas négliger ce qui permet
d'optimiser l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires il y a sur ce point des
innovations qui doivent être déployées
le plus largement possible enfin on veut
pouvoir s'appuyer sur ce qui a
fonctionné élargir le travail fait dans
le secteur des fruits et légumes comme
exemple de notre méthode de
planification écologique à l'ensemble
des filières dans une approche
mobilisatrice transversale et qu'on
pourra décliner opérationnellement
filière par filière merci Monsieur
medevielle Merci monsieur le ministre
nous sommes tous d'accord sur la
planification et nos injecteurs en ont
besoin ils ont besoin de cette égalité
entre agriculteurs européens ils ont
besoin de lisibilité ils ont besoin de
visibilité de confiance et qu'on arrête
les tabous sur une agriculture
productiviste parce que nous avons d'une
besoin d'une agriculture qui produisent
[Applaudissements]
la parole est notre collègue Max Brisson
pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci Monsieur président monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
mercredi dernier vous avez partagé
l'émotion des élèves et des professeurs
du lycée Saint Thomas d'Aquin de
Saint-Jean-de-Luz je vous en remercie ce
drame absolu n'a pas grand chose à voir
avec la violence qui gangrène nos
collèges et au lycée où la difficile
détection des situations de détresse des
adolescents de ces sujets nous
reparlerons quand l'émotion sera passée
pour l'heure je voudrais vous narrer
l'histoire d'un inspecteur d'académie
venu dans un petit village de France
calculer le nombre d'élèves attendus
pour la prochaine rentrée par la fenêtre
d'école plusieurs maisons en
construction devant accueillir dans deux
ou trois ans des familles avec enfants
mais ce qui se passera dans deux ou
trois ans n'intéresse pas Monsieur
l'Inspecteur d'Académie l'école à la
prochaine rentrée perdra trois élèves
trois élèves en moins un professeur en
moins une classe qui ferme tel est le
verdict ce rituel immuable qui sent bon
la Quatrième République
[Musique]
pour vous
répondre la parole est au ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
Monsieur papendaï Merci Merci monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Max
Brisson je m'associe bien sûr à
l'hommage que vous venez de rendre à
Agnès LaSalle assassiné dans l'exercice
de ses fonctions elle consacrait sa vie
à ses élèves et mes pensées vont à sa
famille à ses collègues et à ses élèves
tout atteinte contre un professeur porte
atteinte à la République c'est ce que
j'ai dit sur place avec Stanislas
Guérini le ministre de la Fonction
publique avec vous-même avec la
sénatrice Espagnac et avec le maire de
Saint-Jean-de-Luz Jean-François Irigoyen
à propos de votre question la carte
scolaire tient compte bien sûr d'une
manière générale de la baisse des
effectifs scolaires qui sera j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire dans cette
hémicycle très importantes l'année
prochaine ce qui nous amène à fermer des
classes ici à en ouvrir là dans votre
département des Pyrénées-Atlantiques
nous comptons environ 450 élèves de
moins l'année prochaine tout en veillant
à ce que le taux d'encadrement
particulièrement dans les régions
rurales continuent de s'améliorer ce qui
sera en effet le cas dans votre
département des ajustements d'ici au
mois de juin vont avoir lieu en
particulier sur quelques points
sensibles
éventuellement ceux que vous connaissez
tout en donnant priorité au RPI les
regroupements pédagogiques
intercommunaux donc aux zones rurales à
propos de pluriannuel nous avons un
regard pluriannuel sur les évolutions
démographiques qui nous est fournie par
les statistiques du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale ainsi que par les
rectorats mais il faut aussi tenir
compte des variations annuelles des
migrations des familles qui s'installent
des déménagements ce qui oblige
effectivement à construire annuellement
une carte scolaire mais nous conclure
encore au stade des ajustements je vous
remercie monsieur Brisson
iques je vous ai parlé de procédures de
la carte scolaire je crois qu'il est
grand temps que l'on travaille avec les
associations d'élus pour entrer dans une
démarche plus réelle les mères n'en
peuvent plus d'avoir un comptable chaque
année dans leurs écoles qui viennent
calculer le nombre d'élèves alors qu'ils
savent comme lotissement est en cours de
préparation et que dans un an dans deux
ans il y aura à nouveau des enfants
c'est cette vision comptable qu'on vous
demande d'abandonner pour une démarche
plus réelle
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue
Jean-Michel Arnaud pour le groupe de
l'Union santé
alors que l'agriculture biologique a
longtemps été favorisée par les pouvoirs
publics au nom de l'impératif écologique
elle est aujourd'hui à la marche des
priorités gouvernementales le plan
national stratégique dans le cadre de la
Pâques supprime l'aide aux agriculteurs
bio l'Agence Bio est sous-financée et
les dispositifs de soutien sont très
insuffisants depuis quelques décennies
les pouvoirs publics promettaient un
soutien massif aux pratiques vertueuses
une souveraineté alimentaire accrue est
de meilleure débouchés pour nos
agriculteurs quelle est la situation
réelle aujourd'hui les modes de
production sobrent en énergie et
respectueux la biodiversité sont peu
reconnus et nous constatons une baisse
des ventes des produits bio notamment
depuis la crise sanitaire le contexte
économique ne conforte en aucun cas les
conditions de travail de ceux qui nous
nourrissent en s'insupportable des coûts
de production freinage des exportations
signatures de traité de libre-échange
quand le Mercosur souvent synonyme de
concurrence déloyale
le marché bio étant en situation de
surproduction avec une demande toujours
plus morose au regard de l'inflation
actuelle ce déclin est comme un vers
dans la paume il ne faut pas laisser
pourrir la situation que compte faire le
gouvernement aujourd'hui pour contrer
cette situation difficile et
particulièrement difficile pour les 60
000 exploitants agricoles bio de ce pays
merci
pour vous répondre la parole est
ministre porte-parole du gouvernement
Monsieur Olivier Veyron merci monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
Jean-Michel Arnaud j'ai répondu tout à
l'heure déjà à votre collègue sur le bio
peut-être commencer par dire que on aime
le bio et on a besoin de nourrir
l'ensemble des Françaises et des
Français et on a aussi besoin de
développer notre filière bio pour la
consommation nationale et aussi pour
l'export un des leviers je vais
peut-être m'arrêter davantage sur
celui-ci dans ma réponse c'est la
restauration collective pourquoi je dis
ça parce que on a un objectif dans la
loi egalim vous le connaissez qui est
50% de produits de qualité et durable
dans la restauration collective dont 20%
de bio c'est un levier qui est majeur et
que nous souhaitons améliorer très
fortement qu'il s'agisse des écoles des
collèges et lycées mais aussi des EHPAD
et des entreprises c'est aussi une
manière de changer durablement les
pratiques de consommation alimentaire
que d'introduire massivement le bio dans
ces restaurations collectives alors il
se trouve que depuis 2018 on a fait face
à plusieurs événements plusieurs vents
contraires d'abord la crise du covid
évidemment
que la restauration collective a perdu
transitoirement 40% de son chiffre
d'affaires du fait des mesures
sanitaires mais aussi actuellement le
contexte d'inflation que nous
connaissons depuis plusieurs mois qui
rend difficile un bilan précis depuis
cette année et mais on voit que les
gestionnaires de restaurants collectifs
doivent renseigner leurs résultats et
gallimes sur la plateforme ma cantine ça
va nous permettre de disposer
prochainement de données plus étayées
qui seront naturellement communiqués au
Parlement il y aura aussi besoin
d'accompagner la filière car améliorer
améliorer la qualité des repas en
restauration collective ça passe aussi
par la lutte contre le gaspillage
alimentaire une réflexion sur les
quantités qui sont servies ou encore les
recettes utilisées la première ministre
a pris une circulaire le 29 septembre
dernier qui permet également d'aider
tous les établissements publics à
renégocier leur contrats et donc à
acheter au juste prix il y a une
réflexion qui est en cours avec les
différents ministres concernés afin de
rechercher des dispositifs adaptés à
chaque segment de la filière de
restauration collective atteindre
l'objectif égalim nous le voulons ça
représenter a un potentiel
d'augmentation d'environ 10% du chiffre
d'affaires de la filière ça viendra plus
que compenser les baisses en vente bio
constatées pour l'année 2022
oui c'est le ministre je crois qu'il
nous faut une vraie politique de
promotion de la filière bio et de
soutien en faveur de cette agriculture
biologique clarifiée les labels
actuellement existants ou encore inclure
systématiquement comme vous l'avez
rappelé l'agriculture biologique dans
les projets alimentaires territoriaux la
souveraineté alimentaire doit aussi
passer par une meilleure attractivité du
métier d'agriculteur et je pense à cet
instant particulièrement aux
arboriculteurs alors que le groupe
Carrefour mettent en tête de gondole des
pompes polonaises nous avons cultures ne
s'en sortent pas il leur manque 20
centimes de marge des marges qui
effectivement ne sont pas aujourd'hui
payés à la hauteur des coûts de
production l'agriculture biologique
comme celle conventionnelle sont
confrontées aussi à l'impossibilité de
lutter contre les espèces invasives
alors que nombre de traitements sont
homologués au niveau européen la France
par le biais de lancès maintiennent
l'interdiction générale de plusieurs
traitements y compris bio qui se
cantonnent à des dérogations successives
en envoyant un message négatif aux
clients comme je l'ai souvent entendu
dans les travées du Salon International
de l'Agriculture il y a quelques heures
maintenant en France nous avons trop
souvent le droit de manger ce que nous
avons pas le droit de produire conclure
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Eric Wauquiez pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste merci
monsieur le président madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Miss de
l'agriculture mais je sais Monsieur
Veyron que c'est vous aujourd'hui qui
avait chaussé les bottes
l'association Terre de Liens publiés
hier un rapport très intéressant sur la
propriété des surfaces des terres
agricoles en France en pleine semaine du
salon de l'agriculture les constats
présentés sont de nature à générer de
grandes inquiétudes pour l'avenir de
notre agriculture il y a en France
496000 chefs d'exploitation agricoles
mais seul 35% des terres cultivées
appartiennent aux agriculteurs le
rapport présente un phénomène nouveau on
voit se développer des sociétés
agricoles dont certaines sont financière
risées celles-ci possédait 7% de la
surface agricole il y a 20 ans ce
chiffre atteint aujourd'hui
14%. on découvre ainsi que de grands
groupes comme Chanel ou L'Oréal achète
des terres agricoles les capacités de
l'innovation financière sont décidément
illimitées nous le savions nous
connaissions la finance des villes nous
découvrons aujourd'hui la finance des
champs ces sociétés possèdent
aujourd'hui 640 000 hectares ces
pratiques font flamber le prix hectare
rendant par conséquent difficile l'accès
de petits agriculteurs aux terres et
favorisant aussi les exploitations de
très grande taille au cours des 40
dernières années deux enquêtes
statistiques pour étudier la structure
de la propriété des terres agricoles ont
été menées par le service statistique du
ministère de l'Agriculture or depuis 30
ans le ministère ne recueille presque
plus aucune donnée monsieur le ministre
ma question est double tout d'abord
n'est-il pas tant de procéder à un audit
complet afin de prendre la mesure de ce
phénomène nouveau et deuxièmement nous
pensons qu'il y a urgence à renforcer la
régulation foncière agricole la future
loi d'orientation agricole ne
devrait-elle pas être l'occasion d'en
lancer le chantier merci
pour vous répondre la parole
au ministre porte-parole du gouvernement
monsieur Véran monsieur président et
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur
Eric Bocquet vous m'interrogez sur la
financarisation des terres agricoles et
vous avez raison il y a de la
concurrence sur l'usage du foncier et la
préservation des terres agricoles c'est
une priorité pour le gouvernement
partagé donc c'est un sujet de
souveraineté agricole et de souveraineté
alimentaire alors il y a des outils de
régulation qui ont été mis en oeuvre
dans la préguerre le contrôle des
structures les actions des affaires le
statut du fermage on bénéficie ainsi en
France du prix du foncier parmi les
moins chers d'Europe et cela permet de
maintenir la diversité des modèles c'est
un élément essentiel par ailleurs deux
avancées législatives importantes ont
été réalisées cette fois-ci lors de la
précédente législature c'est un peu plus
récent et vous les connaissez d'abord la
zéro artificialisation nette sur lequel
le Sénat est très engagé
avec avec la dispositions qui prévoit
que les documents de planification
régionale intègre des objectifs de lutte
contre l'artificialisation des sols la
mise en oeuvre également d'un contrôle
renforcé des opérations sociétaires
issues de la loi du 23 décembre 2001
dites la loi sans pesto à l'instant un
dispositif d'autorisation administrative
préalable en cas de cession de titres
sociaux uniquement si l'opération
confère le contrôle de la société au
cessionnaire et lorsque les surfaces
ainsi contrôlées dépassent un seuil
d'agrandissement significatif enfin vous
le savez nous avons lancé une grande
concertation sur le pacte et la loi
d'orientation et d'avenir agricoles
l'objectif nous voulons installer des
agriculteurs en leur donnant les moyens
de s'adapter aux conditions climatiques
techniques et économiques de demain les
questions de fonciers seront évoquées à
cette occasion comme vous le savez vous
venez de l'appeler de vos vœux il s'agit
pas que de levier législatif nous devons
construire cela bien sûr avec les élus
locaux et notre objectif commun c'est
donc de pouvoir agir rapidement avec des
outils opérationnels
je pense qu'il y a véritablement urgence
sur cette problématique une ferme sur 10
est aujourd'hui une société financarisée
et je citerai en conclusion la première
phrase du rapport de Terre de Liens je
cite le jour où nos ancêtres ont fait de
la terre une marchandise est un jour
noir pour l'humanité
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Laurent saumon pour le groupe les
républicains
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre on achète des œufs venus de
l'étranger pondus dans les cages que
nous avons vendues des cerises parce
qu'on a arraché les cerisiers et bientôt
pommier et noisetier on va acheter le
poisson déchargé de bateau battant
pavillon étranger parce qu'on a détruit
on détruit notre flotte alors qu'on se
targue d'avoir le deuxième domaine
maritime mondiale déjà les fruits et
légumes faute de main d'oeuvre peut-être
les endives laissées en terre faute à
une énergie trop cher combat de
concurrents d'EDF le sucre ou les
lentilles malgré le plan protéines
importées de pays où sont autorisés des
traitements interdits ici ajoutez à cela
l'angoisse des règlements des contrôles
des injonctions contradictoires des
charges administratives et l'incertitude
des revenus soumis aux négociations
annuelles vous voyez le comte de fées ne
fait pas rêver la profession agricole
qui s'interroge sur la place réelle et
l'avenir que vous lui réservez la ferme
de France exposée à ces rencontres
s'exposent cette semaine en lettres
capitales pour proclamer la qualité des
productions et l'engagement des hommes
et des femmes pour des produits
respectueux des exigences sanitaires et
durables protégés les consommateurs et
notre environnement croyez-vous que les
agriculteurs refusent de mettre des six
pans pourraient prendre plus de nitrates
dont les cours ont plus que triplés
croyez-vous que les agriculteurs ou les
industriels ont attendu les déclarations
du président parlant de l'eau sur la fin
de l'abondance pour l'économiser alors
que les entreprises comme Christ à
l'Union dans la Somme huselot même des
betteraves pour leur cycle de production
de sucre et ne puise rien dans les
nappes pour gagner en compétitivité et
répondre aux exigences environnementales
l'agriculture est soumise à la nature et
au temps faites-vous résigner le choix
de son déclin ou d'une agriculture
vitrifiée et d'importation ou in vitro
peut-être la ferme France a besoin de
connaître le cap pour qu'elle adapte son
évolution dépendant de la recherche
technique génétique les moyens alloués
et le pas de temps nécessaire ce temps
politique c'est maintenant monsieur le
ministre quel est votre ambition
pour vous répondre
la parole est au porte-parole du
gouvernement
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur
sénateur Laurent saumon alors d'abord je
peux vous dire pour le coup à titre
personnel que je partage le constat que
vous avez fait de dire que les
agriculteurs ne nous ont pas attendu
pour identifier des solutions il se
trouve par exemple que vous citez
l'entreprise cristallinion d'usine de
betterave qui est capable de recycler
totalement l'eau figurez-vous que je
suis allé voir sur place dans l'usine
pour constater avec eux qu'ils avaient
déjà mis la charrue avant les boeufs
mais dans le bon sens du terme puis
qu'ils ont réduit énormément leur
consommation énergétique et quasiment
arrêté la consommation d'eau ce qui veut
dire que c'est possible mais ce que nous
devons faire nous comme état c'est être
capable d'abord de collier ces bonnes
pratiques de les enregistrer de les
reconnaître de les soutenir mais aussi
être capable de s'aimer dans l'ensemble
des entreprises du secteur agricole et
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
c'est ça qu'on appelle restaurer la
compétitivité de la ferme de France
c'est aussi partir de ce qui fonctionne
sur le terrain de l'exemple qui nous est
montré par celles et ceux qui aiment
profondément la terre cultiver et
nourrir les Français et c'est ce que
c'est vraiment notre ambition alors il y
a eu un rapport du Sénat qui montrait
que depuis 1990 il y avait eu un
effritement progressif de la
compétitivité la ferme France et c'est
pour ça qu'on veut vraiment identifier
des solutions depuis 2017 il y a eu des
choses qui ont été faites on a mis par
exemple le revenu agricole au cœur de
notre politique je pense à la loi egalim
2 que vous avez voté merci pour cela
pour que le juste prix se soit plus
seulement le prix bas mais c'est tout
simplement celui qui permet à nos
agriculteurs de vivre c'est une vraie
rupture avec la loi LME précédente et
vous aurez prochainement l'occasion
d'assurer la prolongation du SRP plus 10
qui est un des leviers des gallimes
c'est également pour cela que nous avons
initié des transitions ambitieuses avec
le varen de l'eau c'est important de
pouvoir regrouper tout le monde encore
une fois de discuter ensemble et
d'identifier des bonnes solutions je
pense aussi à la réforme de l'assurance
récolte ou le travail mené sur la
réutilisation des eaux usées parce que
les agriculteurs qui sont bien souvent
les premières victimes ne savent
parfaitement l'adaptation au changement
climatique la souveraineté alimentaire
c'est un même combat c'est cela que nous
appelons la logique de la planification
écologique et ça va rejoindre la logique
de la planification agricole et c'est un
projet porté à bras le corps par le
ministre en charge de l'agriculture
évidemment par la première ministre
monsieur le ministre en 20 ans la France
a vu son industrie déclinée nous
apportons désormais voiture médicament
jusqu'à notre électricité demain si vous
ne remettez pas en cause vos choix nous
perdrons nos agriculteurs les vocation
et notre souveraineté alimentaire nous
avons laissé notre industrie décliner
n'en faisons pas de même avec notre
agriculture redonner confiance à nos
agriculteurs que nous n'ayons pas à
répéter au président ce que Fénelon
écrivait en 1694 à Louis XIV la France
est devenue un grand hôpital désolé et
sans provision
merci
[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue Christian
Redon s'arrosit pour le gros socialiste
écologiste et républicain
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre hier puissance agricole et
deuxième exportatrice mondiale de
produits agroalimentaires la France est
passée au cinquième rang en 20 ans c'est
importants ont suivi le sens inverse et
représente toujours lui près de la
moitié des produits consommés par les
Français chaque jour nous ne sommes plus
le grenier de l'Europe nous sommes
déficitaires en matière alimentaire
depuis 2015 le nombre d'exploitations ne
cesse de 10 minutes tout comme les
cheptels et l'on observe un taux
inquiétant de déconversion dans
l'agriculture biologique après 5 ans et
demi d'action gouvernementales les
situations les agriculteurs ne s'est pas
améliorées loin de là le taux de suicide
chez les exploitants agricoles et le
plus élevé de toutes les catégories
socioprofessionnelles la transmission
des exploitations reste un problème
majeur en 25 ans le prix des terres
agricoles aura doublé dans 10 ans 50%
des chefs d'exploitation seront en droit
de partir à la retraite la profonde de
crise des vocations s'explique avant
tout par l'absence de revenu décent et
par le coût de plus en plus élevé du
foncier agricole la proposition de loi
pour lutter contre l'accaparent du
foncier agricole déposé par votre
majorité avant les les présidentielles
de 2022 n'a répondu en rien à la
problématique de concentration du
foncier et des outils de production
alors actuelle l'état démontre manque
total d'ambition or les crises se
succèdent et vont se multiplier très
rapidement
entrez à quel point notre agriculture
était fragile la France est déjà depuis
un mois en situation de sécheresse le
véritable modèle récolte français que
nous voulons défendre doit être pérenne
familiale respectueux des humains des
animaux et des sols et c'est celui qu'il
faut préserver à tout prix nos
territoires et nos citoyens ont besoin
de la polyculturellevage de la
multiplication des circuits courts des
relocalisations avec des chaînes
d'approvisionnement alimentaire sur non
soumises aux aléas climatiques
et géopolitiques préserver nos
souveraineté et notre sécurité
alimentaire est un gage d'indépendance
et de survie à cet égard les intentions
de l'État quant à les ratification des
accords UE Mercosur du CETA de l'accord
libre-échange avec la Nouvelle-Zélande
autant de portes ouvertes à une
concurrence déloyale ne sont toujours
pas claires monsieur le ministre nous
avons besoin d'une trajectoire
d'adaptation précise et cohérente face à
tous ces enjeux et le temps presse quand
allez-vous proposer une véritable
politique agricole
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Monsieur Véran porte-parole du
gouvernement oui monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Christian Redon
sarrazzi je vous écoute on peut être que
d'accord sur le constat que vous faites
vous avez raison de rappeler que d'ici
une dizaine d'années près de la moitié
des agriculteurs sera parti à la
retraite et qui nous faut absolument
rentrer dans une logique de
renouvellement des générations vous avez
raison aussi de souligner qu'il faut
profiter de ce renouvellement des
générations ça avait été le cas
d'ailleurs dans les années dans les
années 60 lorsqu'il y avait eu une
planification agricole avec déjà un
grand renouvellement générationnel dans
le monde agricole il faut pouvoir
accompagner les transitions c'est à dire
avoir répondre à la demande des jeunes
agriculteurs qui sont des gens qui
aiment la terre qui aiment cultiver qui
veulent être propriétaire de leurs
moyens de production et qui veulent
pouvoir vivre de leur travail décemment
ainsi la question du revenu est une
question qui compte elle est pas unique
mais c'est une question qui est centrale
avec les lois egalim 1 et 2 nous avons
mis fin à la spirale déflationniste et
la destruction de valeur pour nos
agriculteurs ce sont des lois
intéressante nous devons travailler à
leur plein application au-delà nous
devons surtout assumer un discours clair
collectivement nous voulons une
alimentation saine sur durable
respectueuse de l'environnement et de la
biodiversité et oui monsieur le sénateur
tout ça ça a un prix nous voulons garder
un outil de production agricole en
France ne pas dépendre des importations
étrangères qui n'ont pas les mêmes
standards c'est ce qu'on appelle aussi
la souveraineté alimentaire française et
oui cela a un prix et c'est la même
logique que celle de la réciprocité des
normes que nous avons ancrées dans le
débat européen depuis la présidence
française le revenu agricole c'est aussi
une retraite digne et des avancées ont
été adoptées en la matière je salue
notamment les lois Chassaignes 1 et 2
mais aussi la loi d'Yves que le Sénat
vient d'adopter qui prévoit que le
gouvernement devra travailler aux
conditions d'une pension calculée sur
les 25 meilleures années à partir de
2026 et avec la réforme des retraites
dont vous vous saisissez on va permettre
concrètement d'améliorer revaloriser 350
000 retraites avec 100 euros en plus en
moyenne pour une carrière complète enfin
monsieur le sénateur l'avenir de
l'agriculture s'est assumé accélérer les
transitions vous l'avez dit je partage
je n'insiste pas merci la parole est à
notre collègue Jean-Sol pour le groupe
les républicains
sur le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues avec le réchauffement
climatique la question de l'eau est de
plus en plus préoccupante l'été 2022
marquée par une sécheresse record et
généralisée à nattes l'eau est
indispensable à une multitude
d'activités comme elle était
indispensable aux grandes équilibres des
milieux naturels notre pays c'est doté
d'une législation qui vise en équilibre
entre les différents usages de l'eau il
s'agit de répondre à nos besoins tout en
préservant la ressource à travers toute
une série d'outils un de ces outils est
le débit réservé la loi interdit de
prélever dans un cours d'eau si cela
conduite à réduire son débit en dessous
d'un certain seuil et ce pour préserver
la faune et la flore aquatique si le
principe est vertueux j'attire votre
attention sur ces difficultés
d'application et les dérivent auxquelles
nous assistons saisis par des
associations de protection de
l'environnement le juge administratif
est amené à fixer les débits réservés
bien au-dessus de se décider par les
préfectures dans les pionniers
orientales des prises d'eau sur le
fleuve Coty la tête qui servent à
alimenter les canaux d'irrigation
ancestraux faisant vivre une agriculture
maraîchère familiale sont
condamnésatrinopérantes et vous permet
par décision du juge qui a estimé que
les calculs des services de la
préfecture pourtant très compétents et
type erronés se basant sur d'anciennes
études de volume prélevables par
ailleurs contestées le juge fait une
application maximale des textes en
s'écartant de l'objectivité d'équilibre
entre les différents usages de l'eau au
risque de condamner les activités
maraîchères locales et de faire
disparaître le système des canaux qui
contribue pourtant à la biodiversité
locale ailleurs à Sallanches en
Haute-Savoie cette même interprétation
maximaliste du débit réservé pour y
conduire un interruption du lieu
centrale hydroélectrique neuve madame la
ministre ma question est simple
envisagez-vous de modifier les modalités
d'appréciation du débit réservé pour
éviter de décimer les agriculteurs en
les empêchant d'accéder à l'eau
pour vous répondre la parole de
calaminés dans Charles des collectivités
territoriales et de la ruralité
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur seul
je vous demande à nouveau d'excuser
Christophe Béchu et nous partageons le
diagnostic que vous posez l'année 2022 a
déjà été marquée par une sécheresse
prolongée intense et étendue 93
départements étaient contraintes
d'adopter des restrictions d'eau et 75
départements ont subi des situations de
crise les perspectives pour 2023 sont
donc suivis avec attention d'ores et
déjà 5 départements font l'objet de
restriction en raison de la sécheresse
de l'année dernière et du déficit de
précipitation que nous connaissons
actuellement nous avons au niveau de
nappe globalement dégradé par rapport à
l'année dernière avec deux mois de
retard sur le niveau de recharge le
niveau de précipitation dans les mois
qui viennent sera crucial pour
déterminer la situation dans laquelle
nous serons l'été prochain notre rôle
est bien sûr d'anticiper la situation et
d'encourager encore et toujours
la sobriété des usages avec Christophe
vichu nous sommes pleinement mobilisés
nous poursuivons le travail
d'anticipation absolument nécessaire des
décembre je l'ai déjà dit à madame la
sénatrice Carrère tout à l'heure les
préfets ont été chargés d'identifier les
collectivités fragiles en matière
d'alimentation en eau potable pour les
accompagner prioritairement les agences
de l'eau pourront mobiliser en 2023 100
millions d'euros d'aide supplémentaires
en faveur des projets de résilience
territoriaux les préfets coordonnateurs
de bassins ont également été réunis le
27 février pour planifier des solutions
liées aux problèmes de raréfaction de
l'eau
la prochaine réunion aura lieu le 6 mars
un plan sur l'eau sera présenté dans les
prochaines semaines dans le cadre de la
planification écologique portée par la
première ministre nous nous engageons à
travailler sur les sujets que vous nous
avez porté dans votre question merci
monsieur le sénateur monsieur
les acteurs de terrain de la politique
de l'eau madame la ministre ne peuvent
plus se contenter de réponse dilatoire
il y a l'urgence à modifier les textes
sur l'eau pour prendre en compte les
besoins légitimes de nos territoires
sinon les prochaines saisons s'annoncent
explosives je vous invite aussi à vous
emparer des propositions du rapport
récent de notre délégation à la
prospective pour éviter une panne sèche
généralisée je vous remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Alain Dufour pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste il avait la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame première
ministre madame monsieur les ministres
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre
l'agriculture bon il n'est pas là mais
je pense que madame Dominique fort va me
répondre sur ce sujet nous avons connu
en 2022 une sécheresse importante et au
début de cette année 2023 la question a
été posée à monsieur le Président de la
République dans le cadre du Salon de
l'agriculture il a répondu qu'il fallait
prendre des arrêtés de restriction au
niveau des préfets mais également
proposé dans le cadre d'infrastructures
le développement et la mise en place de
retenue colinéaire c'est dans le sujet
qui vous est proposé aujourd'hui j'avais
déposé une proposition de loi faisant
état de la mise en place de retenue
colinéaire de petites tailles pour des
superficies de boite de 150 000 mètres
cubes
expérience elle n'est pas contraire aux
règles de l'écologie et aujourd'hui ma
question monsieur le ministre madame la
ministre pardon c'est de savoir si vous
allez soutenir ce dossier je ne pense
pas que les territoires est attendus le
Salon de l'Agriculture pour vous poser
véritablement cette question qui me
paraît tout à fait pertinente car
effectivement les agriculteurs les
éleveurs les vignerons de ce pays
entendent de votre part une réponse
particulièrement précise et efficace
pour les rassurer définitivement merci
pour vous répondre la parole que madame
Dominique fort ministre délégué en
charge des collectivités territoriales
[Musique]
je renouvelle toutes mes excuses pour
l'absence de Christophe Béchu et je
passe brièvement sur les réponses
sur les réponses que j'ai déjà apportées
sur le diagnostic que vous posez
sur ces sécheresses estivales et qui
nécessitent nécessite tout anticipation
que je viens de citer et je viens à la
question des retenues colinaires en fait
pour vous dire qu'il n'y a pas monsieur
le sénateur de dogmatisme il faut les
apprécier au cas par cas chaque projet
qui respectera les critères exigeants
que nous fixons pourra être validé le
stockage hivernal lorsque les expertises
techniques le juge soutenable pour les
milieux lorsqu'il s'inscrit dans un
projet territorial largement concerté et
lorsqu'il participe de meilleurs partage
de la ressource peut-être une solution
les stockages hivernaux font partie du
panel des solutions à mobiliser par
contre ce n'est pas l'unique solution et
sur beaucoup de territoires cette
solution ne sera pas techniquement
possible soyez assurés que nous serons
particulièrement vigilants sur les taux
de remplissage de ces ouvrages dans le
contexte actuel particulièrement tendu
je vous remercie
monsieur Dufour
madame la ministre nous serons vigilants
les agriculteurs seront vigilants à la
mise en place de ce dispositif car
aujourd'hui il faut être dans l'action
mais non pas dans l'ingantation les
Français attendent d'une manière
générale des résultats tangibles et
vérifiables voilà la réalité merci
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Catherine
benretti pour le groupe les républicains
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
de la transition énergétique chère
collègue la crise actuelle a mis en
évidence la dépendance énergétique de la
France tant financière que quantitative
et il me semble indispensable de
consolider à la fois nos filières de
production énergétique et de
développement durable sans y sacrifier
notre indépendance aujourd'hui la
Moselle nous en fournit les moyens et je
vous ai écrit à ce sujet il y a déjà
plusieurs mois trois forages de
recherche ont permis d'identifier un
immense volume de gaz certifié de paix
le gisement du gaz lorrain représente au
total un volume de 190 milliards de
mètres cubes de gaz soit environ 5
années de consommation de gaz pour la
France d'un point de vue technique son
exploitation présente l'avantage décisif
de ne pas recourir aux techniques de
fracturation hydraulique ou d'autres
procédés polluants à la différence
notable du gaz de schiste de sorte que
l'utilisation de ce gisement réduirait
de 10 fois l'empreinte carbone de la
fourniture de gaz actuel
aujourd'hui une entreprise française se
tient prête à assurer l'exploitation de
ce gaz à investir près de 20 millions
d'euros et à créer de nouveaux emplois
pour se faire il serait même possible
après extraction du gaz de réaliser des
enfouissement de CO2 dans le sous-sol
ainsi libéré le temps de l'action est
donc venu il est suspendu à l'accord du
gouvernement concernant l'attribution
d'une concession d'exploitation à
l'entreprise qui se fait attendre depuis
maintenant trois ans cet accord
renforcerait notre souveraineté
énergétique au regard de nos relations
extérieures avec d'autres pays et d'un
contexte global imprévisible il
contribuerait à stabiliser notre
situation économique marquée par une
hausse du prix du gaz et du coup
supporté par les entreprises et les
ménages il traduirait enfin notre
engagement sur le plan écologique et en
venir en mental si vous partagez ces
objectifs madame la ministre
l'exploitation du gaz lorrain peut-elle
compter sur votre soutien
pour vous répondre parole est au
ministre de la transition énergétique
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sellatrice belerie je mène au nom du
gouvernement une politique énergétique
qui vise à sortir notre pays de sa
dépendance aux énergies fossiles cette
dépendance qui pèse encore pour deux
tiers dans notre consommation
énergétique finale d'autres stratégie
vous le savez elle repose sur trois
piliers la sobriété l'efficacité
énergétique puisqu'il faudra réduire
notre consommation de 40% d'ici 2050 si
nous venons tenir notre objectif de
neutralité carbone c'est tout le sens du
plan de sobriété que j'ai présenté avec
la première ministre en octobre dernier
qui a permis de réduire notre
consommation d'énergie de 10% cet hiver
nous avons finalement fait en trois mois
ce que nous n'avions pas réussi à faire
en 30 ans le deuxième pilier c'est la
production massive d'énergie
renouvelable c'est tout l'objet du
projet de loi qui a été largement adopté
sur ses bancs au mois de février le
troisième pilier enfin c'est celui d'une
relance historique de notre filière
nucléaire là encore un projet de loi que
vous avez adopté qui sera examiné ce
soir à l'Assemblée nationale dans cette
stratégie madame la sénatrice nous
devons mobiliser toutes les ressources
de production disponibles sur notre
territoire en privilégiant les moins
carbonés c'est dans ce contexte que les
services de l'État instruisent le projet
d'exploitation de gaz de souche de
couches en Lorraine de la société
française de l'énergie sur lequel vous
m'interrogez ce projet ce projet il vise
à extraire du méthane contenu dans les
veines de charbon il a fait l'objet
d'une enquête publique qui a mobilisé la
population avec plus de 500 observations
déposées en majorité défavorable au
projet les actions les associations
environnementales locales se sont
également exprimées contre ce projet car
vous le savez contrairement au gaz de
mines qui lui s’échappe de manière
fatale et qu'il est donc important de
valoriser puisqu'il va directement dans
l'atmosphère je porte la plus grande
vigilance sur ces projets de gaz de
couches qui consiste à investir dans une
énergie fossile l'instruction de ce
projet est en cours de finalisation
concernant conformément au Code minier
et je serai amené à me prononcer dessus
d'ici quelques semaines je vous remercie
alors l'étude qui avait été faite et les
questions qui ont été posées ça s'est
situé avant la crise que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui
je pense que les gens seraient
favorables à plutôt exploiter un gaz
mosellan plutôt que d'importer un gaz de
schiste des États-Unis merci Madame
la parole est à notre collègue Annie le
verrou pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre malgré les moyens
du Ségur de la santé et ses promesses
d'attractivité pour l'hôpital public
l'hôpital public continue de faire face
à un accentélisme important et palier au
nombre postes vacants si l'intérim
médical est nécessaire pour répondre aux
difficultés temporaires de recrutement
l'usage abusif qui en effet conduit je
vous cite à un intérim cannibale qui
rémunère injustement le nomadisme
professionnel détruit la cohésion des
équipes certains professionnels sont
devenus de véritables mercenaires de la
santé font monter les enchères
hebdomadaires du marché de l'intérim à
2000 3000 euros par jour voire plus sur
certaines périodes tendues en
comparaison un jeune praticien à
l'hôpital perçoit un salaire mensuel
d'environ 4500 euros pour un engagement
sans limite auprès de ses patients pour
répondre à cette injustice la loi de
2021 a encadré les tarifs de l'intérim
médical avec un plafond fixé par décret
à 1170 euros minutes pour une mission de
24 heures son application prévue en
octobre 2021 a été décalé afin de
prévenir les dysfonctionnements à un
mois de la mise en oeuvre de la nouvelle
échéance fixée au premier avril nous
sommes alertés par les praticiens
hospitaliers notamment dans les services
d'urgence qui peinent à boucler les
plannings faute d'intérimaires acceptant
les nouveaux tarifs avez-vous envisagé
la réquisition de ceux qui profitent du
système au mépris du serment
d'Hippocrate pour éviter des fermetures
de lit ou d'urgence quelle mesure
avez-vous prises pour éviter un nouveau
recul dans le respect du temps de
travail des praticiens hospitaliers
titulaires et des patients qui ne
doivent pas être les victimes
collatérales de cette guerre de tranchée
entre le ministère et ses mercenaires
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de la santé ou de la
prévention Monsieur François Brown merci
monsieur le président mesdames
messenatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice le héros la
régulation de l'intérêt médical est une
constante et une préoccupation du
législateur depuis au moins deux
mandatures et vous avez rappelé
récemment une loi la loi risque 2021
c'est aussi attaché à ce sujet
je suis aussi très attentif au fait que
votre assemblée le Sénat surveille de
près la mise en application des lois
c'est pour cela que je me suis engagé à
mettre les décrets d'application de cet
article sur l'intérim médical en action
des débuts avril bien entendu et vous
l'avez dit cela ne vise pas l'intérêt
médical habituel mais bien les dérives
de l'intérim médical c'est des rives qui
forte heureusement ne sont que minorités
dans l'ensemble de l'intérêt médical
c'est d'abord une question d'éthique
mais même au-delà de cette question
éthique il faut rappeler quelques
chiffres vous l'avez fait
359 millions d'euros c'est le coût pour
les hôpitaux de l'intérim médical en
2021 vous parliez de chiffres jusqu'à
3000 euros ça va même jusqu'à 5000 euros
les 24 heures là où le cadre vous l'avez
rappelé de 1170 euros au-delà du côté
financier c'est aussi un véritable outil
à détruire les équipes hospitalières et
l'engagement des praticiens là où vous
avez deux médecins qui font le même
travail et l'un est payé trois fois
quatre fois 25 fois plus que l'autre
pour la même période alors depuis plus
d'un mois j'ai demandé aux ARS d'animer
des concertations locales territoire par
territoire avec les préfets avec les
élus pour affiner les diagnostics
établissements par établissement j'ai
également je leur ai également demandé
de construire des solutions avec les
professionnels de santé du territoire
mais également avec les CHU les
établissements siège de ght dont c'est
la responsabilité j'en appelle également
aux acteurs du privé des cliniques
privées qui se sont engagées envers moi
à suivre le même sens dans la
rémunération raisonnée de ces périodes
d'intérim médical je suis bien sûr avec
une attention très particulière
l'ensemble des établissements et des
établissements qui sont en fragilité et
je peux vous assurer qu'aucun territoire
ne restera sans solution
le cri d'alarme des professionnels et
moi je crains l'impossible mis en œuvre
du plafonnement du prix de l'intérim qui
démontreait une fois de plus l'échec de
votre politique de santé qui nécessite
d'être revue de fond en comble avec la
profession je crains que le respect du
nouveau tarif ne soit un poisson d'avril
au mépris de ceux qui s'engagent pour
l'intérêt général auprès des patients et
sans reconnaissance
la parole est à notre collègue
Jean-Claude anglar pour le groupe les
républicains vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
transition énergétique madame la
ministre alors que la France dispose du
parc hydroélectrique le plus important
de l'Union européenne que ce parc
produit 12 % de la production nationale
d'électricité et qu'il est essentiel
pour le mix énergétique sa situation est
aujourd'hui fragilisée par des années
d'indécision les 340 ouvrages exploités
sous le régime de la concession de
service public
font face à l'absence de renouvellement
des concessions échues dont de nombreux
ouvrages dans la vallée de la Truyère et
du Lot en Aveyron la situation du parc
hydroélectrique est nécessite une action
urgente et déterminée en raison des
conditions de renouvellement des
concessions échues exploité en délai
glissant et du contexte juridique
modifié par la réglementation européenne
après la privatisation le démantèlement
d'EDF prévu dans le projet Hercule sur
lequel je vous avais déjà interrogé ici
même il y a deux ans et qui aura
provoqué de nombreuses oppositions
contre lui le gouvernement est resté
dans les spectative en ce sens la Cour
des comptes a adressé une véritable mise
en garde au gouvernement le 6 février
dernier en soulignant la nécessité de
sortir rapidement de cette situation
afin d'éviter que la situation ne se
dégrade plus encore et je cite oui
madame la ministre il est urgent de vous
intéresser à ce problème dernièrement
l'hydroélectricité n'a pas été abordé
dans le projet de loi relatif à
l'accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelable ni dans celui
visant à accélérer la construction de
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires vous
pouvez toujours vous abriter derrière
l'annonce d'un prochain grand texte sur
le sujet mais en attendant l'effet sont
là alors madame la ministre pourrait
vous pouvez vous nous dire si vous
partagez le constat sévère de la Cour
des comptes sur l'inaction du
gouvernement pouvez-vous nous dire si
vous partagez la solution consistant à
ceux que les concessions soient fondées
sur un ensemble de considérations
économique et juridique madame la
ministre dites-nous vos difficultés sous
le sujet et nous pourrons vous aider
comme la Cour des comptes vient de le
faire je vous remercie pour vous
répondre de la parole est au ministre de
la transition énergétique madame panière
une
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur anglar le gouvernement porte
une grande attention à l'énergie
hydroélectrique et à son développement
cette énergie renouvelable et pilotable
est essentielle vous le savez à la
teinte de nos objectifs climatiques mais
également à la sécurité
d'approvisionnement des Français ainsi
qu'à la bonne gestion de la ressource en
eau aujourd'hui la France compte plus de
2600 installations hydrauliques qui ont
représenté près de 11% de la production
électrique française en 2022 le secteur
hydraulique vous l'avez rappelé
contribue aussi à l'économie locale au
travers des emplois créés dans les
vallées vous avez cité celle du lot de
la truillère mais également de la
Dordogne ou des Pyrénées la Commission
européenne a engagé un très contentieux
vis-à-vis de la France portant notamment
sur l'absence de renouvellement par mise
en concurrence des concessions
hydrauliques échues comme vous l'avez
évoqué la Cour des comptes a présenté un
rapport sur ce sujet le 6 février
dernier en réponse à la Cour des comptes
le gouvernement a indiqué qu'il
explorait plusieurs scénarios pour le
nouvellement des concessions qui doivent
satisfaire 5 objectifs clairs relancer
rapidement des projets de développement
actuellement bloqués par le contentieux
européen dont des projets de STEP gardez
la pleine maîtrise de notre parc
hydraulique que pourraient fragiliser
des remises en concurrence favoriser les
synergies dans les usages de l'eau et
faire en sorte que l'ensemble des
bénéfices générés par l'exploitation des
concessions bénéficient infinies à la
collectivité et disposer enfin de
contrats souples avec des possibilités
de modification assez vastes pour
adapter ces dernières aux évolutions des
besoins à court terme et peut-être cela
vous a échappé le projet de loi relatif
à l'accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelable adoptée le 7
février dernier permet désormais de
réaliser les investissements insurant la
pérennité des ouvrages hydroélectriques
dont la concession est échue quel que
soit la solution retenue le gouvernement
sera très attentif à la préservation du
potentiel énergique technique et humains
des sociétés hydrauliques
hydroélectriques et alors ancrage
territorial merci la parole est de notre
collègue Cyril pelva pour le groupe les
républicains
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
est le fruit d'une concertation
transpartizane je la pose au nom des
sénateurs membres du groupe
développement économique de la montagne
que j'ai l'honneur de présider nous
sommes tous vivement inquiets par la
situation économique des stations de ski
particulièrement les plus petites qui se
trouvent aujourd'hui dans une situation
intenable d'asphyxie financière du fait
de la hausse des coûts de l'énergie
l'ensemble des activités économiques et
industrielles sont bien évidemment
touchées mais certaines sont plus
pénalisées que d'autres ce qui nécessite
un accompagnement complémentaire de la
part de l'étain c'est le cas des
domaines qui ABL qui subissent
actuellement une double peine tout
d'abord les domaines skiable subissent
de par leur activité une discrimination
tarifaire au regard du mode attribution
de la reine prévue par les textes
d'avril à octobre alors que les plus
gros pics de consommation des domaines
ce skiable ont essentiellement lieu
durant la période hivernale de plus
malgré la mise en oeuvre d'aide
appréciée et attendues des acteurs
économiques de la montagne le dispositif
décrètement de la reine vient
sensiblement réduire l'effet amortisseur
de prix attendu ce qui fragilise des
structures et notamment les plus petites
comme les rég de monter mécanique
actuellement plus de 40% des domaines ce
qui a français ont récemment du
renégocié leur contrat d'électricité
avec des prix vous pouvant être
multipliés par 10 et des pénalités
exorbitantes en cas de rupture anticipée
de nombreux petits domaines se trouvent
donc aujourd'hui au bord de la faillite
et pourrait déposer le bilan si le
gouvernement n'agit pas pour les
collectivités supports de station qui
seraient défaillantes la prochaine étape
laisse peu de doute la mise sous tutelle
par la chambre régionale des comptes ce
qui serait dramatique pour tous
l'écosystème montagnards madame la
ministre j'avais alerté le ministre
Bruno Le Maire au mois d'août du risque
qui pesait sur les sur les stations il y
a maintenant urgence comment
peuvent-elles absorber une hausse des
coûts de l'énergie qui passe de 3 à 20%
d'un chiffre d'affaires ainsi j'ai
plusieurs questions
comment comptez-vous adapter les
dispositifs d'aide pour que les
traitement ne viennent plus annuler le
bénéfice des aides et ce notamment pour
les régies dans montée mécanique comment
comptez-vous prendre en compte les
spécificités de domaine skiable pour la
future réforme de la reine qu'en est-il
de la possibilité de renégocier les
contrats maintenant que les prix se
stabilisent des annonces ont été faites
il y a quelques semaines qu'en est-il
aujourd'hui merci pour vos réponses la
parole et que la ministre déléguée en
charge des petites des moyennes
entreprises madame Oliviera Grégoire
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur pas de question porte sur les
effets de la hausse des prix de
l'énergie sur les stations de ski vous
le savez le gouvernement a mis en place
plusieurs dispositifs d'aide et assez
tôt d'ailleurs les sénateurs vous l'avez
mentionné mais aussi les députés élus de
la montagne ont échangé avec tout à la
fois Bruno Le Maire et moi-même et vous
le savez très bien
les régies par exemple sont absolument
intégrés aux aides que nous avons
déployé autant pour moi je vous
cherchais je vous remercie que nous
avons déployé que nous continuons à
déployer ça n'est pas une annonce
anodine il est donc bien prévu ça va
mieux en le répétant que les régies qui
ont une taille équivalente à nos PME
dans l'acception européenne jusqu'à 250
salariés soit couvertes par
l'amortisseur électricité soit parce
qu'elles ont une personnalité morale
soit presque elles sont d'une
collectivité qu'elles ont rattachées à
une collectivité territoriale elle-même
bénéficiaire du dispositif
il vous a pas échappé qu'ayant l'honneur
d'être à la fois en charge des PME et du
tourisme monsieur le sénateur d'abord je
suis proche des élus de la montagne mais
aussi des acteurs économiques j'étais
encore au salon de la montagne il y a
pas si longtemps je veille avec beaucoup
d'attention pour que l'ensemble des
régies soient accompagnés et je vous le
dis comme je l'ai dit à l'ensemble des
élus de la montagne si vous avez des
exemples spécifiques de régie qui ne
rentrerait pas dans la grille que je
viens de vous dire n'hésitez pas à me
saisir
moment où on se parle je n'ai pas eu à
date ça veut pas dire que demain il y en
ait pas de remonter
dramatique concernant des régies par
ailleurs je tiens quand même à dire dans
ce tableau un peu noir mais c'est le
charme de l'échange que ce faudrait pas
oublier non plus les fantastiques
résultats des acteurs de la montagne qui
les chiffres sont sortis hier font des
résultats remarquables 42% de nos
compatriotes ont l'intention d'aller au
ski au cours de l'hiver 2023 en janvier
2023 on a un taux d'occupation qui est
en hausse de 17% par rapport à janvier
2022 et pour février on enregistre une
hausse de quasiment 12 points du taux de
réservation par rapport à la même
période il y a un an et perspectives
sont belles le gouvernement est là et
pour ma part je reste à votre
disposition si vous avez des sujets
spécifiques je vous remercie
nous en avons terminé merci madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres avec les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement les
prochaines auront lieu le mercredi 8
mars à 15
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h30 pour le débat
d'actualité sur le thème des
conséquences de l'inflation sur le
pouvoir de choc des Français la séance
est suspendue